you're not doing it to put a smile on
someone's face you know what I mean like
uh we're doing it because it's like
selfish so you [__] give up
relationships sure it absolutely Emily
sometimes you go away from people it's a
very selfish Endeavor you know in so
many you want to throw a big word out I
love it you threw Acumen out earlier did
I all right I said your dad had no
business acumen
sorry a good thing we're we're friendly
that's uh that's another sign of
Baltimore disrespect using too many
syllables with a man you just met could
end up in a could end up in a
switchblade
that's my stabbing Acumen you piece of
[__]
you think you're [__] better than me
I don't know I could say Ackerman too